uh
welcome to the second day of our
workshop
today we're particularly happy to have
uh sergio hart
uh joining us from israel
so sergio of course is a professor of
mathematics and economics from the
hebrew university of jerusalem
of course he's uh he's one of the
foundational uh
people in the area of learning games
and uh of course we know that already
because although already in the in the
first day of the workshop we've been
discussing about his work and we're
particularly happy that he's uh
he'll come and uh he'll share us all of
his knowledge on his uh
true
expertise on forecasting hedging and
calibration
thank you very much sergio and please
the floor is yours thank you
okay thank you and uh
so
that was georges you spoke i mean
because i have no no idea who is
speaking yes
yeah okay uh
i see the only thing i see i see uh
behind the view of the of the auditorium
so i have no clue
whether you will be following my talk or
whether everybody's asleep or what
happens so
it's like speaking in the dark you know
so i try to do my best
if you if things are not clear shout or
something i don't know
i guess i should be able to hear you
if anybody wants to ask questions okay
so uh
so let me start i want to talk about uh
forecast hedging calibration and end
game equilibria it doesn't appear in the
title but uh it's going to be part of
the talk
uh
so uh
um
this joint work with dean foster from
upenn and amazon amazon new york
and
there is a paper which just appeared in
jpe
that contains
the most of what i'm going to talk today
but not everything
are also some other papers
that are relevant
in particular let me advertise the last
paper on kali beating
which i guess you have no clue what it
is very good so come to my talk in in
the next there is another workshop in
may beginning of may
where i am going to present that paper
so uh
in some sense this is the the first part
and the second part will be
in may i don't know if it's the same
people or not but you're all welcome
unless you'll hate what i say today
okay so
and by the way you can find all the
papers and everything on my webpage
including this presentation maybe an old
version i'm not sure i updated it but
i'll make sure that i update it uh later
today by the way just just a question
how long do i have
how much time is the talk
one hour
one hour okay very good
okay so let's start with we're going to
talk about forecasts okay
so
you you turn on your tv or your iphone
or whatever and you see something like
there is a 70 chance of rain tomorrow
okay
very good
uh that's what
the weatherman says by the way let me
tell you that when i was a kid much much
before any of most of you at least i
have no idea but most of you for sure
were born
there was one profession that everybody
was making jokes about there were
cartoons about it
and that was weather forecasting there
were those cartoons of the weather
forecasting saying tomorrow is going to
be sun and then the next the next frame
you see him
drenched in rain or tomorrow it's going
to rain and he was going with an
umbrella and the sun was shining
high in the sky okay everybody was
laughing about the weatherman and how
bad they are
today people do not laugh
at the weather prediction
now one answer is they got much better
at it i have a different answer once
upon a time whether prediction was it's
going to rain tomorrow or it's not going
to rain tomorrow today weather
prediction is there is a 70 chance of
rain tomorrow and it doesn't rain i mean
i only said 70 i didn't say for
certainty problem solved right i mean so
long as you don't say zero or one or
zero percent or a hundred percent then
you cannot be shown wrong okay well
that's not really true uh because we
we can check what happens okay so the
forecaster says there is a 70 chance of
rain tomorrow or more generally there is
a chance p
of rain tomorrow
and how do we check okay if you if you
have never thought about this problem
it's in fact a very good question and
the answer they take some time to get
the answer okay so to or to get an
answer there are many answers but let me
tell you
the the simple answer the simple answer
is the following
let's look at all the days when i
forecasted 70 of course you cannot check
me after one day you can check me say at
the end of the year okay or after a
certain period let's say capital t
periods
we can check my record okay and let's
look at all the days when i said 70
if i'm a good forecaster
amongst those days
among 70 percent should have been rainy
days
right and that should hold for any
forecast that i'm using
the days when i said 50
half of them should be rain half of them
should be shined okay
if that is true so for every p the
forecast p that i'm using the proportion
of rainy days among those days when the
forecast was p this proportion equals p
or is close to p the long run then we
say that the forecaster is calibrated
okay that means that when he said
seventy percent indeed seventy percent
of those days is going to be right
okay
now let me start immediately with the
total okay but let me give you a
parameter to this story okay i have no
idea about weather forecasting i never
studied mythology earth sciences or
anything i have no idea about clouds
nothing okay i have no no connection
with it nevertheless
i can guarantee
calibrated forecasts i can generate a
sequence of forecasts that is going to
be calibrated and when i say guaranteed
it means no matter what the weather will
be
no matter whether of course we can be in
a situation you know like in israel in
the summer there is no rain so
very easy
chance of rain zero percent no uh the
rain is completely arbitrary in fact
since uh i met again at a computer
science
audience there is an adversarial
rainmaker okay whose only aim in life is
to make my forecast look bad he doesn't
care about rain for agriculture or
anything else he just cares about my
reputation as a forecaster and
the rainmaker is trying to make me look
bad
i have news for this rainmaker whoever
that is the smartest one could be
nevertheless i can guarantee calibration
okay and uh that's that's an amazing
thing again i i want to emphasize this
is completely non-baja there is no
assumption on some statistical structure
or any regularity on the weather the
weather can be completely arbitrary i'm
not assuming that you know there is some
markov process dictating it or anything
i mean complicated model whatever it's
completely arbitrary okay the weather
can be anything rainmaker is free to
choose whatever they want okay
now this result is due to dean foster
and ricky vora uh 1994 i think that
perhaps probably the head before there
published 1998 now again this is not in
computer science you are used to the
fact that there is a conference
proceeding
you know and then the published paper
maybe 20 years later if at all okay
in economics that's not how it works
okay usually you have a paper you
immediately send it to a journal and
it's accepted you know may take a year
or two anyway this paper
they really had a hard time publishing
it they would send it to a journal two
weeks later it was you know still
without email i think maybe it was email
or time already so i know this from
being foster they'll get a desk
rejection this result cannot be true i
mean how can you guarantee calibration
without knowing anything about the
weather okay that's nice because we
don't care that you have a proof we
can't check the proof i mean there is
some fallacy there okay and they
keep getting rejection after rejection
until they succeed in publishing okay
now i'm going to give you a proof okay
oh sorry before that i want to emphasize
for the continuation
that the forecasting is going to be a
mixed forecasting and and just not to
get confused for example the forecaster
is going to choose a certain day and
toss a coin and this probability one
half is going to say chance of rain 25
percent with probability one half is
going to say chance of rain sixty
percent okay so there are here many
numbers between zero and one forecast
i'm always going to use them as
percentages and probabilities will be
you know like one half so is the
probability of a certain forecast the
forecast itself is also a number between
zero and one so not to get confused okay
so let me show you now the proof
uh
using the minimax story okay
now uh
in this audience of course i don't have
to show you what the minimax story but
here it is okay
for neumann storm and the reason i show
you is because that's not how you should
teach the mini max story i mean it's a
very neat mathematical statement but
that's completely
you know mean max equals max mean you
have no clue what it is here is how this
should be
taught by the way it took me a few years
to realize that that sounds this should
be done here is the minimax term it says
if for every strategy of the opponent i
have a strategy such that my payoff is
at least seven
whatever
some number then i have a strategy that
guarantees a payoff of seven no matter
what the opponent does so again that's
something that uh in logic is completely
no no it says
for every
for every strategy of trauma that exists
and then i'm interchanging the two
operators and say i have a strategy that
is universally good against anything
your opponent will do
that's the minimum acceleration okay
that's why it's not a triviality okay if
again it depends how much you take for
granted but proving it takes some effort
okay it's a good tool but i want to be
careful
you need you need a few assumptions you
need the game to be finite okay if the
game is infinite that this statement is
false okay
for example you know name the highest
integer
name the highest integer then
whatever the opponent does you can name
a higher integer but there is no highest
integer that you can name okay
uh
also one is to look at mixed strategies
probabilistic strategies in order for
this term to be correct okay so now once
we have this term then the calibration
theorem is is immediate here is the
proof okay
so let's suppose that i want to get
let's say 10
calibration error okay just for
simplicity okay so i'm going to use a
grid a 10 grade my my forecasts are
going to be 0 10 20 up to 100
i have 11 possible forecasts every day
okay so look at the game between me the
forecaster and the rainmaker
i as a forecaster have 11 choices every
day the rainmaker has just two choices
every day rain or no rain okay and that
is repeated day after day okay
uh
and assume that i fixed the horizon
capital t or
say one year okay we'll talk in a moment
we'll talk later what is that horizon
capital t
then uh if the strategy so again what is
the minimum theorem said for every
strategy of your opponent you have a
reply so if i if i'm given a strategy of
the opponent what's the strategy of the
opponent a strategy of the opponent a
mixed strategy of your opponent
translates every day to a certain
probability of choosing rain and the
complement probability of choosing sun
okay
now uh
um
that's a general strategy again
houses probabilities are determined
maybe depend on history may depend on
many things i don't care but in the end
if i know the strategy then i know
exactly
every day given what has happened up to
that day what is the probability that
the rainmaker will choose rain what am i
going to do i'm going to take the
probability round it up to 10
to multiple of 10 percent and that's
going to be my forecast so clearly
when the probability of rain is 65
or 66 let's say i say 70
okay so when i say 70 it's when the
probability of rain is something between
65 and 75 percent which means that there
is going to be
for the forecast of 70 percent a 5 error
let's say 10 because also there is a lot
of large numbers even if the probability
is always 66 percent it doesn't it may
happen that there will be no rain any
day so i need enough periods to make
sure that the law of large number works
okay
for the cornerstones
uh t to the power three uh sorry uh
t equals to the number of of possible
forecasts to the power three suffices um
but close parentheses okay so if i know
the strategy of the opponent then of
course i can get calibrated forecast the
minimax term says you don't have to know
anything there is a strategy of the
forecaster that guarantees no matter
what the rainmaker will do that uh
you get calibrated forecasts now that
sounds really amazing yes i must say
it's amazing yes
uh unbelievable i mean uh how come i
mean without knowing anything you can
guarantee
nevertheless it's a corrector okay and
uh and it's a beautiful program uh
um
i'm quite proud of this i came up with
it when i dean foster gave a talk in
jerusalem on that and as he as he
presented it the other complicated proof
i said wait a minute i can prove it
immediately with the minimax problem
okay uh by the way it's uh um
i'm giving talks like this for uh for
many years now
and every time i say look here is a
challenge
this is the beautiful use of the minimax
donut you start from something
completely trivial if you know the
strategy of the rainmaker of course you
can give calibrated forecast because you
know the probability of rain every day
okay that's the triviality the
conclusion you can guarantee calibration
without knowing anything it's completely
unbelievable so that's really a really
beautiful use of the minimax theorem
and challenges find me a better use okay
there are many uses of the minimum story
by the way in computer science it's
called yao principle many times uh and
there are many beautiful uses of that i
still believe that that's the most
beautiful one the most
clean and neat and gives you something
really amazing
okay now so let's go back as i said
that's the result so first of all
original proof that's my proof using the
minimax story now my proof again is is
very neat but it doesn't tell you how to
do it okay it just says there is
now there is you know it's a big game so
who knows what it is well it turns out
that there are methods to do it so one
method is based on blackboard
approachability it's due to andromeda
and myself
which is again quite simple it's a it's
a simple way to do it i i won't get into
details then dean foster simplifies this
even further
and then in fact i'm going to show you
an even simpler way to do it
which is this paper that i'm presenting
now okay it's extremely simple way to do
it
okay now let me before before doing that
let me let me emphasize one thing
is that calibration cannot be guaranteed
if the forecast
is known to the rainmaker
before the rainmaker decides on the
weather okay because what the rainmaker
is going to do if my forecast is above
50 percent there will be some if my
forecast is below 50 there will be rain
torrential rain just to make the point
okay that means that that
the calibration error the error between
the distance between my forecast what
has really happened is at least one half
okay that one half is big it's a bigger
yes
uh so if the forecasts leak a leak in
the like wikileaks yes not like the roof
leaking but like wikileaks kind of
leaking leakiness so if a forecast has
known
before the decision is made on rain or
no rain by the rainmaker then of course
calibration cannot be guaranteed okay
remember that
of course if the forecaster uses a
deterministic strategy
then again since he uses a deterministic
strategy the rainmaker will know exactly
what the forecast is
because it will just emulate the
strategy of the forecaster
and so we are getting a gain to the
situation of leaky forecast which means
forecast is known
to the rainmaker so again calibration
cannot be guaranteed okay
very good if there are any questions or
then please shout to do something or
okay i'm assuming everything is crystal
clear because i can't see any private
space so
okay um now that's related to the
comments of oaks and so on okay now uh
let me
plug in another another
another
notion
which is continuous calibration now
calibration the notion of calibration is
a very discontinuous notion i only find
it exactly but
anybody can write down the formulas i'll
show you some formulas later it's not
important i mean i think the notion is
clear it's the distance between forecast
and what is the the average the average
number of rainy days that happen for
that forecast and you average this in
the right way yes that's uh it doesn't
really matter how you do it okay now the
problem is that when i look at what
happens when my forecast was 70
and when i look at what happens when my
forecast was say 69
okay those are very close forecast but
those are separate days because the days
when i said 70
are considered separately from the days
when i said 69
that's what makes the the calibration
score and the whole calibration problem
very discontinuous and these convenience
problems
make problems so let's try to smooth it
out let's try to make it continuous okay
so let's introduce the notion of
continuous calibration that says the
following when i want to compute my
calibration error which is difference
between forecast and realization average
realization i'm not just looking
say for 70 percent i want to know the
error for 70
well i look at the days when i said 70
but i also look at days when i said
something close to 70
say between 69 and 71 slows it out in
some manner okay details don't matter
you can do it in many different ways but
it's it's the same thing so that's
continuous calibration continuous
calibration says let's loose out the
calibration score okay
so let me give you another result okay
here's another result
when i can guarantee continuous
calibration sure since i can currently
calibration of course i can guarantee
continuous calibration because if i can
make the forecast of 70 good and 69 good
and 71 good that average is also going
to be good
but
notice now i claim there is a
deterministic procedure that is
continuously calibrated okay
there is a procedure that is
deterministic
and it guarantees continuous calibration
now if you come if you think back about
my previous slide we said well if it's
deterministic then in principle or in
practice the rainmaker will know what my
forecast is going to be every day which
means he can beat me right
well not not so okay so surprisingly he
cannot beat me
okay so there exists a deterministic
procedure so there exists a mixed
procedure that guarantees calibration
and there exists a deterministic
procedure that guarantees continuous
calibration and this result is very
important
so what it says that even if forecasts
are leaked nevertheless one can get this
continuous calibration now uh this
result is stated now which uh so there
were some other results close to it in
the literature foster and cocaine and uh
foster and heart our previous paper from
2018 but uh
but they were much they were more
technically uh complicated and they were
not clean really now we think that we
have really the right notion of
continuous calibration and also the
right proof and i'm going to talk about
it it's not going to be essentially a
very simple
one line or two line proof kind of kind
of thing it's very neat okay very clean
okay so let me start with a simple
illustration okay i think that that's
that's going to give you some idea of
what we are doing
and uh and we are talking about rain
forecasting okay so
uh a time t
how do i compute the the
the scope okay so i'm looking for each
forecast p that has been used and let n
of p be how many days p has been used in
the past so i'm now considering the
forecast
that i'm going to make it period t and
i'm looking at the history which is t
minus one days and i'm and n of p is how
many days n of n of p of course depends
on the has a substring t minus one there
but i'm simplifying no subscripts just
to get you'll get the notion so this is
the number of days that p has been used
how how many times i use this forecast
in the past and rfp how many rainy days
there were out of those lp days okay
so let's let me then define g of p which
is the gap
if i were perfectly calibrated
then the number of rainy days amongst
those days those np days where my
forecast was p should have been np times
p
right if i if there were n days when i
said 70
then n times 0.7 should have been the
number of rainy days
the difference between the actual number
of rainy days and my forecasted number
of rainy days which is np times p we
call it the gap at p or it's an excess
the number of excess rainy days
and here is a standard simple score that
i'm going to use i'm just going to take
the sum of squares
forget how this is normalized now
believe me that when you do the
organization right everything comes out
correctly but ignore the normalization
now okay it's uh
again it's a simple illustration just to
see what's going on okay you can look in
the paper and see the things
little more details and correctly done
okay so now i'm a time t
and assume that my forecast at time t
let's call it q it's a number between
zero and one
and let a
stand for the rain situation at period t
so rain is a it takes the value zero or
one
no rain or rain okay
and now i want to say to see how the
score s changes so let me remind you
what the score is the score is the sum
of gp square where gp is this formula
here so clearly the only thing that
changes there is g of q of the forecast
i've used the forecast that i haven't
used nothing has changed there
how does gq change well
up to now i had gq squared in the sum
and now what happens gq is the number of
rainy days where the number of daily
days has increased by one if it was rain
or zero if not rain in short has
increased by eight
the number of
forecasted rainy days
namely n of q has increased by one so n
of q times q has increased by q so i
have to add a and subtract q
i hope that you follow this very very
complex computation okay so this this
difference is a change in s okay
now
this thing let's do a first order
approximation or if you want you you
open the parenthesis okay gq squared
cancels out you have twice gq times aq
and then you also have eight minus q
squared and let's ignore the a minus q
squared as i say it's it's okay to
ignore it okay that's uh
it comes up okay so the first order
approximation of this quadratic
difference is just the derivative it's
twice gq times a minus q
okay so now
here is what so let me put it again this
is this is the change in s
so here is my aim
let me try to guarantee that this change
is never positive which means that the
sum of squares doesn't go up okay
can i do it
well remember a is not under my control
q is under my control so if i have a q
such g of q is zero let me let me choose
that then clearly delta is going to be
zero no matter what a will be
but what if i don't have such a q what
do i do well i can't guarantee that this
is going to be less or equal to zero no
matter what a is so let me
let me try more modestly let me try to
to forecast q q is remember is my focus
in such a way that this inequality is
satisfied on the average no matter what
a will be
okay so i want the expectation of delta
okay
how to do it we'll see in a moment okay
but now
what this thing is called is forecast
hedging we named this
dean foster and i forecast hedging
one reason is that it has the right
initials you know fh
but it's really focused hedging the same
way as you do hedging in finance okay
hedging in finance which is essentially
like insurance okay you don't know
whether the
the exchange rate within the dollar and
the pound is going to go up or down and
you have made some so what you do you
buy some some options on the dollar or
on the exchange to make sure that no
matter what will happen to the exchange
rate your position will be the same you
don't want to you are not going to lose
money you are not going to gain money
but you are going to insure yourself
against the change in the exchange rate
okay that's called hedging in finance
hedging is a very important tool that's
why options you have you can sell short
because you can do many contracts short
you can you can there are lots of lots
of methods to do that and and the whole
idea is you want to hedge the risk
the same way here we want to hedge the
forecast we want to make sure that no
matter what the weather is going to be
because remember we have no control over
the weather is this our first adversary
rainmaker that chooses the weather we
want to make sure that this delta is
going to be small
okay so
the case where i can make delta less or
equal zero no matter what a is that's
deterministic forecast edging the quiz
the case where i can do this only in
expectation on average that's stochastic
forecast edging okay so the mystic
forecast hedging is easy i find the
point where g is zero i forecast it but
if there is no such point i am in
trouble so let's try the stochastic
forecast engine and here is how we are
going to do it so remember our a okay
and remember what delta is i put here
delta again is g of q times a minus q
so here is how i'm going to do it i'm
going to use just two forecasts q1 and
q2 q1 is probability p1 q2 is
probability p2 so i'm going to randomize
between two forecasts q1 and q2
okay
uh if i do that what is this expression
the expectation of delta well it's p1
gq1 times a minus q1 plus p2 gq2 times a
minus q2
so let me realize this in the following
manner so essentially i took the term
with a and put it so i replaced in the
last in the second term a minus q
with a minus q1 and then i can take a
minus q1 out of the parenthesis and then
i'm left there with this difference
between q1 and q2 times p2 gq2
i hope you can follow the very complex
algebra okay
okay so how do i make this small
to make this small first of all i want
to make sure that a does not enter in
order for that remember that the qi and
the pi i choose them i'm the forecaster
and i choose it so how do i choose them
i choose them so that first of all the
expression in blue
the expression that multiplies a the
coefficient of a is zero that means
i've hatched against a doesn't matter
what a is going to be the result is
going to be the same okay
but i still have the second term so in
order the result to be the same and
small i need the second term to be small
so i do that by choosing q1 minus q2 to
be as small as possible that's how i
make the expectation of delta well not
less or equal zero but let's recollect
okay so let me show you now a picture
so here i have my forecast and let's
assume i just use five different
forecasts you know zero percent twenty
percent forty percent and so on and here
is the function g of p remember g of p
is an arbitrary function yes for every
forecast there is some gap so i put here
some
some arbitrarily those those points
sorry i have six uh
uh
uh six different forecasts zero up to
one or six different forecasts so here's
six points anyway they could be negative
positive for some forecast i was
overshooting i said i there was more
rain than i expected other there was
less rain this is called completely
arbitrary picture so what do i do i find
two points that are
adjacent two forecasts that are one next
to the other such that one is positive
and the other is negative
how do i know i can find that
okay that's a good question with a
trivial answer when i look at the gap at
zero
this must be positive because when i
forecast at zero there can only be a
positive gap that can only be more rainy
days than zero that cannot be negative
number of rainy days when i focus on the
hundred percent the the the g of 100
must be negative
because
uh when i said 100 means every day must
be rain so that so if i'm wrong there
can only be less rainy days so the gap
must be positive at zero and negative at
one which means at some point it must
switch from positive to negative
so here is that point for example it may
do it more than one time i don't care so
i do that and what do i do i choose q1
and q2 to be those two adjacent
forecasts which are the distance of the
grid
uh and i take the probabilities so that
their average exactly gives me
zero okay so i take the probabilities to
be inversely proportional to the
distance between the intersection point
and t1 and q2 okay remember the formula
what i want is p1 gt1 plus p2 gq 2 to be
0 and that i guarantee exactly by
choosing q1 and q2 with the right
weights so that the average of those two
points is exactly zero okay and as i
said i can always do that
okay now
in the same picture here is the case of
deterministic forecast hedging i have a
point q where this is zero that's when i
focus that's
the case where i focus this q and i and
i have deterministic forecast hygiene
stochastic forecast engine i don't have
such a point well i imitate it by two
nearby points and taking the right the
correct average
okay
so
uh
let me give you a result
this procedure that i just described i
mean it's as simple as you can do every
period you just have this graph and you
just find two points and you you don't
need any any heavy computer yes you can
do it by hand yes and you just use the
the probabilities given by the
intersection there okay this turns out
to be delta calibrated the calibration
error is delta no more than delta where
delta is the mesh size i mean the
distance between two adjacent points
okay uh the proof is not so easy by the
way but but it's not very dif i mean now
we have enough machinery that we can now
do it but this is as simple as you can
do i mean it's really the simplest
possible procedure it's much simpler
even the the currently i mean the
previously simplest thing which was dean
foster's
1999 procedure that required to keep
track of much more things and was much
less natural this is very simple okay as
i said you essentially find
probabilistically a forecast where the
gap is zero
deterministically or on average okay
now it's important to to understand that
the randomizations are always between
two forecasts that are delta apart
so this is a procedure that is
stochastic but it's almost deterministic
yes if your grade is one percent it says
that your forecast is going to be
randomization between say 71 and 72
so the focus is essentially known within
one percent
okay just the last the the least
significant digit is not known okay
uh
another thing to notice suppose that the
function g were a continuous function
it's not a continuous function it's a
discrete function defined on the grid
but suppose that i i did some smoothing
out of the function g
parenthesis that's what continuous
calibration does
then if the function g is continuous
then i can always find a point where
this continuous function that starts
positive and that's negative must cross
the horizontal line and that's exactly
my deterministic forecast edging okay so
that gives you already a hint how one
gets deterministic continuous
calibration
now all this is just for weather
forecasting which means that the
realization every day is a binary
realization rain or no rain but in
principle one can do this in higher
dimensions i mean weather forecasting
doesn't have to be just vain you can
talk about temperature which is a
variable that takes many many possible
values you can talk about rain there you
can tell sorry about
about
donald stones and
winds and whatever so you can have many
dimensions and of course it's good not
not only for weather it's good for many
other things okay so in general what we
saw in this simple illustration indeed
extends okay
deterministic forecast hedging means we
want to choose q so that this inequality
is satisfied for all a that's a hedging
the hedging says no matter what a is
going to be i want this inequality to
hold
how do i obtain that turns out i need
for this a fixed point total but our
fixed point error okay
on the other hand if i want to get this
only in expectation
then i can obtain this by minimum story
okay a minimum store and try to find a
game okay which you know for other
people in minimax is like uh you know
dual it's like linear programming okay
it's polynomial okay okay now that's a
big difference i hope that i mean in
this audience i'm sure i don't have to
explain the difference between
continuous fixed point and finite
minimum they are very different classes
uh so but that's an important
distinction so we are going to talk
about fp procedures for the fixed point
procedures and we are going to talk
about mn procedures for the minimax
procedures and we are going to i'm going
to talk about this distinction which
again is very important and you know it
much better than i do
okay uh
p-pad and all those things i mean uh
that's really
beyond me but but
i'm sure that you you guys know this
okay now uh
the title and everything we're talking
is forecasting okay
but once you look at this forecast
hedging approach to focusing um
really there is no forecasting here
okay i do i don't believe i i have no
clue what the weather is going to be
tomorrow forecasting means that i'm
looking forward okay i know something
forward there is no forecasting there is
something else here something that we
call back casting what is bad casting by
casting means look backwards okay
essentially what you do you look at the
track record what has happened until now
and you choose the forecast in such a
way that no matter what the weather will
be your track record can only get better
that's the hedging okay
so
i have no again let me repeat because
that's a very important point all this
is is is crazy in terms of forecasting
as if i know something about the future
i have no clue about the future but
what i do i can take the past i can look
at my track record and i can make sure
that i choose my forecast today in such
a way that whether it will rain or
whether it will be no rain my track
record can only improve on average again
on average then you need some article
tolerance to make sure that this works
okay but that's uh that's what happens
yes we even cause it's a politician's
lemma you know i mean what does a
politician want i mean there are
politicians that want you know uh that
want the well-being of their people okay
maybe maybe but uh
here is a more practical view they
really want when they finish their
presidency people to say hmm he was a
good president okay let's build him a
library okay i i think in the u.s you
know this
this kind of thing so you really what he
wants when he finishes it that people
say here the bootleg record
okay so that's what backcasting does
now you think that that's just imaginary
so uh
so let me here i have just uh a couple
of uh just to show you
people can get calibrated focus okay
uh here is uh
538
nate silver's
website and here is its calibration
plots now to understand here it's very
similar to the picture i did but here on
the horizontal axis is the forecast on
the vertical axis is the proportion of
rainy days or the proportion of whatever
they forecasted happening so being
perfectly calibrated means to be on the
diagonal
the picture that i did previously
essentially i took the diagonal and made
it horizontal but it's the same thing
okay so you can see that they are pretty
well calibrated for sports
pretty well calibrated for everything
else and a little less about politics
you see for politics there are more
errors but still it's pretty good
okay
here's another graph from election
betting odds okay again the blue line is
perfect calibration they call it
accuracy but it's really calibration and
that's really what they obtained for
each one of the forecast brackets they
show how much
how success i'm successful what i mean
what was the organization okay now i'm
not saying that forecasters i mean so so
that's a view that says look i can do it
if i can do it clearly people that claim
that they are experts can do it just as
well and you can see here they are
calibrated okay
now
here let me already say if you come to
my advertised lecture in
in may okay at the same same place
different time i guess
um
then you'll see that
to check expertise that's not the way to
do it okay you need something else and
and that's that's the topic that i'm
going to talk there okay now forecast
hedging let's see how much time do i
have okay so i have now some technical
details and i think i'm going to do it
very quickly you can read the paper you
can look on my web page
but uh
[Music]
yes
those things are not difficult but you
know i i want to skip them because i
want to i want to get to
uh i i'll just do it very quickly okay
essentially calibration has to do with
beaming meaning means for example i
chose my beans zero percent ten percent
twenty percent up to a hundred percent
forecasting means i take a certain day
and if i focus seventy percent i put it
in the seventy percent b okay
uh
now
the generalization of that of taking a
forecast and putting in a beam is doing
essentially fractional kind of beaming
which means take a forecast and put it
in the seventy percent being maybe put
also in the sixty-nine percent being a
little of it maybe also in the 71
percent being and that's how you do
continuous calibration okay that's a
generalization of continuous calibration
where each forecast is spread out around
beings in a continuous manner
okay to have an idea you essentially put
it in the 70 percent with a little
flowing around yes like you take a
bell-shaped curve or something like this
doesn't really matter how you do it okay
now uh
remember the gap that to your top here
is the same formula for the gap that we
talked before it's essentially
difference between forecast and what has
really happened
and then the calibration score is
essentially the the sum of squares of
the gaps well now i normalized correctly
you have to divide by the number of
periods
okay so that's now the right calibration
score by the way there are many variants
of that that's the the
the l2 calibration score you can use
different norms but that's a convenient
one okay
now let me i'll do it very quickly i'm
sure nobody will be able to follow but
just to show you how easy it is to get
from deterministic forecast hedging to
calibration so essentially you look at
this gap this shows you the updating of
the gap function doesn't matter if you
follow everything we take this square
and again we open this thing okay we sum
over all beams
like we had before of all possible
forecasts okay and now we want to choose
ct
where remember 80 is not on our control
so the way to do it we we choose ct so
that the
middle the term the last term
appears on the second line is less or
equal zero that's exactly forecast
edging
and then essentially if we succeed in
doing that
then we just get that the score from one
period to another increases by gamma
square which means in t periods it
becomes t gamma squared but remember i
have to divide by one over t squared so
i get one over t gamma squared that's
our proof okay that goes to zero as t
goes to infinity gamma is just a bound
on say one on on forecasts and actions
or whatever happens there that's a
structure of the proof okay it's it's a
complete triviality essentially i mean i
said one line okay it's you know source
algebraic manipulation they're very
simple but the whole idea is that
forecast edging takes care of this term
of the mixture of g times a minus c
essentially we
hedge the effect of a we take our a out
of the equation that's what forecast
agent does and one can do it
okay how well in order to do it you need
to guarantee this and and that is
guaranteed by a fixed pointer as i said
and in a moment i'll i'll
give you a clean statement of the tool
that is needed uh stochastic forecast
hedging is the same except you want to
get the same thing on average
and not so equal zero but that's what we
call epsilon because again there are
errors and to do that
you apply the minimum still okay that is
guaranteed by the minimax star okay
so let me let me again
reiterate or summarize this part if you
use a fixed point
of course you need continuous for your
youth after you do it on continuous
functions you are going to get
deterministic calibration
if you use minimax you are going to get
stochastic calibration the classic
calibration using stochastic or or mixed
forecasts
okay now what does this forecast edging
tools again for the mathematicians uh
those that like they are there is a neat
way to to state them uh so take c to be
a compact convex set and some function f
if f is continuous then there is a point
why satisfying this inequality no matter
what c is going to be
okay c here takes the place of that
weather that is unknown and against
which i want to edge
and this statement is equivalent to
browse fix pointer again look in the
paper you can find
also a lot of discussion on on how to
present this
on the other hand if f is just bounded
but maybe this continues the only thing
i need to be bounded
then i can get a probability
distribution over points y so that the
same inequality holds in average on
average and that turns out to be
equivalent the minimum story
okay
so
again we call this the outgoing there is
a reason there is a calling out going
because the geometry of that talks about
outgoing directions but again
at this point doesn't matter so we have
outgoing fixed point and outgoing min
max that looks look essentially the same
the fixed point says that is the point
the minimum access is the probability
distribution that gives the same result
on your average so those are the what we
call the forecast edging tools
okay
now using that we immediately get
all the classical results on calibration
namely there exists a stochastic
procedure that is epsilon calibrated
that's the the result of fostering water
1998 the original calibration result
second result
there exists a deterministic procedure
that is continuously calibrated again uh
the state the need statement now that
has no epsilon and and lipschitz
constants and so on which
which happened for the previous results
is in this paper
and also there exists a stochastic
procedure that is epsilon calibrated and
that is raw local raw local means it
always uses forecast that you are within
row of one another as close as you want
okay so all these results come
essentially from the proof that i showed
you with some minor modifications that
adapt once putting focus staging
deterministic once putting focus
strategic stochastic
okay
okay now uh
i have something like what uh 15 minutes
right
something like that i even i i'll
probably finish earlier than that but
let me now talk about game dynamics
sorry any questions until up to now
i have a question anybody followed i
need some some some questions
okay any question yes actually yeah uh
if you can go just a couple of slides
before
okay tell me where to stop
here here here that's fine so uh do i
understand correctly that you are
reformulating uh the problem basically
as a variational inequality right
right the first one the first one is
called variational inequality correct
correct okay and so the second i mean we
are not inventing that i mean it's a
known result yes the minimax result we
haven't seen it anywhere but it's neat
to see it one one one next to the other
to see that essentially takes this
variation a thick fixed point uh result
and without continuity you get the same
thing on average
okay and that's a mini max that's
equivalent to the mini max okay yeah
thanks i just want to
to verify my understanding thanks a lot
yeah yeah as i said if you if you care
about that have a look in the paper we
we are very careful in explaining those
things and doing it very carefully and
saying showing the equivalence and
showing what happens and i think it's a
neat it's a neat thing
in fact let me let me even say there is
another formulation of the of the
outgoing minimax
uh let me give you a hint there is
another way i mean this looks quite
strange but it's exactly the tool that
is needed for hedging for the forecast
region it's phrased in the way that
exactly fits forecast edging
if you remember we needed this
inequality g times a minus c to b less
or equal zero and that's exactly what we
have here but if you think but let me
give you another way to think about the
the outgoing minimaps of the
the minimax variant so if you have a
continuous function
uh
say g that goes from c to c there is
always a fixed point let's browse fixed
point only yes c is a compact context
set in some euclidean space correct
okay now the function g is not
continuous what do you do
okay well you can look for an
approximate fixed point now what's an
approximate fixed point is some point
where say gx is close to x but there may
be no such point i mean think of the
function defined on the interval 0 1
that equals 1 up to a half and 0 from a
half on i mean there is no x where g x
is close to x so you cannot get a point
that is approximately fixed point okay
but what you can do
is you can get
uh points where the distance there is a
way to phrase this
that you don't look at the distance
between gx and x but look at the
distance between gx and arbitrary point
in c and you look at how this compares
to the distance of the point x from an
arbitrary point in c
okay and that's that's essentially a
fixed point on the average uh as i said
you can if you if you care about that
look in our in our paper on kali beating
and you'll see this deformation it's i
think it's a useful tool for other
things as well
okay i i guess you got more than you
bargained for when you asked your
questions actually uh yeah but just uh
out of curiousity very quick follow-up
uh just for the outgoing minimax uh so
you're uh you don't need any assumptions
for the for for it i mean it can be
singular it can be whatever
whatever anything in fact the function f
is defined just on finitely many points
on c on a grid that's all i need and
then it's an arbitrary function defined
on a grid
and you apply the minimax you need very
neatly and you get this result it's
quite surprising it's quite surprising
also because it's so much parallel to
the fixed point which is a very very of
course much more heavy much heavier tool
and here you get it by minimax just
applying minimal storage
yeah
thanks
okay
i hope you'll find another use for it
let me know
okay
uh okay so game dynamics let's talk
about gate dynamics which i guess is is
the title of this conference right or
something
or at least part of it so i'm getting
there so calibration is good for many
things but now let me talk about game
dynamics so let's let's think about the
general in-person game finally many
players yes i mean everything's simple
finally many strategic pure strategies
and so on
so
uh let's look at
dynamics of that that consists of the
foreign thing each period players
forecast what's going to happen next
time
i don't know how they forecast but they
have some forecast okay and then what do
they do with the forecast okay
if they believe in the forecast then
they choose that
what they actually do in response to
that forecast okay
now
for this to make any sense focus should
be good forecast okay what does it mean
good to be calibrated okay which means
that when you focus something it's
essentially right because if you focus
something and what's going to happen is
very different than the forecast is
worse
okay
uh
and when players choose an actions in
response to the forecast of course they
should choose it in a good way they
should choose the best response
okay so
we are looking at the class of dynamics
that consist of
forecasting in a good way namely
calibrated what's going to happen next
and replying to it best replying to this
forecast okay
and then we ask what does this ill
okay
so let's look at what's called
calibrated learning
okay which consists of the following
every player every period makes a
calibrated forecast delta calibrated
delta is a calibration error on what the
other players are going to do next
period okay i don't know how they do it
but they do it remember there is a
torrent that says
you can do it i mean i can do it if i
can do it you can do it okay i mean i
give you the recipe okay one can
generate calibrated forecast on anything
there is no there is a term saying that
you can do it that's a forecast
laboratory yes
now you have also very simple methods on
how to implement it okay so each player
forecast what's going to happen next
period okay in a calibrated way and then
each player just chooses the best reply
to that forecast what's going to happen
in the long run okay
so here is a beautiful result of foster
and vora saint foster involved approved
the calibration result dean foster and
ricky vora
in fact this was published before
i mean this is a later paper of course
it was published much earlier because
game tourists immediately understood the
importance of what they do okay so much
more than than economists and
statisticians
so the result is that if you look at the
time average of play
uh what's the time average of play you
are asking you're looking at the
empirical distribution name you are
taking every cell in the matrix every
joint
strategy or joint action that's called
it of the players every n tuple of
actions of the players and you're asking
how often has this been played in the
past
say
t periods okay and you and that gives
you probability distribution over each
combination of actions if it's two
players over each entry in the matrix
okay
and that's a time average of play or
it's the empirical distribution of play
that turns out to be essentially
a correlated equilibrium
from some time t on okay that's a result
of foster voter and in fact once you
understand what one talks about it's not
very difficult to to to prove it because
again think about it if the forecasts
are calibrated so when are you playing
say your action top where you are
playing your action top
when the forecast was such the top was
the best reply
okay
now
let's assume that that happens when the
forecast was 70 percent something so in
the forecast that something happens with
probability 70 percent then you should
play top
well if the focus is calibrated in the
long run when default your focus was 70
about 70 percent of the time happened
what you ex what you thought and then
the best reply against this forecast
when 70 of the time the action that you
expected happened is for you to play top
so you played top when top was the best
thing to do that's exactly what the
correct review means
i'm not sure anybody followed it but you
have to think about it for two minutes
quietly and you realize that that's all
there is to it i mean so it's a it's
very clear
i mean
okay i'm not trying to diminish that
contribution of hostile warrant it's a
beautiful insight okay but once you
understand the inside the proof is is
quite easy okay so that's the result of
australian war again very beautiful
result
now what happens if you if you now let's
use now our more sophisticated tools our
more sophisticated tools say let's use a
continuously calibrated forecast
and i know now that i can do it
deterministically
okay the theorem that says continuous
calibration you can obtain with
deterministic procedures okay so all
players make a deterministic
continuously calibrated forecast on
what's going to happen next period okay
and then everybody
best replies to it and i want to do this
in a continuous way so best reply is not
continuous okay basically like jumps
think about the matching pennies you
know up to a half you want to play one
after a half you want to play zero so
let's let's move it out by taking not
best reply but approximately applied
that means that the jump function now is
becomes a an s function smoothed out but
that means you have just delta must
reply okay
result
most of the time
the
play is going to be a nash approximate
equilibrium okay
so with high probability or in the long
run it's probability one the following
statement is correct you look so i'm now
at period one thousand and i look at all
the periods of one thousand a pillar
capital t capital t being a big number
and i look at all the periods up to
capital t each period i look at the n
tuple of mixed strategies remember best
approximate best reply is a mixed
strategy in the game so i'm looking at
that n tuple of mixed strategy that has
been played in period small t and i do
this for small t from 1 up to capital t
then here is the result
1 minus epsilon of the periods so 1
minus except for epsilon proportion of
the time in the remainder
which means one minus epsilon times t
capital t of those periods
what i'm going to see have been played
in those periods is a nash epsilon
equilibrium so i'm not talking about the
time average
being the correlated equilibrium we are
talking about the period by period play
being almost every period
a nash equilibrium or an approximate
natural here okay much much stronger
result okay
very different result
okay this describes it more formally
let's not get into that so here is the
result so continuous calibration
continuously calibrated learning which
is the procedure that i described
previously
continuous calibration
forecast continuously calibrate the
forecast and then an approximate best
reply by each player is a dynamic that
is first of all uncoupled now uncoupled
is something that
andromeda scholar and i introduced which
i think is a very useful notion
uh it's what you guys called distributed
okay decentralized in economics it says
that you are only using your own payoff
function you you see
actions by other players but you have no
idea what are their utility functions
you have no idea what are their
preferences you have no idea what they
are doing you just
why they are doing what they are doing
you just see what they are doing okay
uh and you react to it using your own
payoff function that's called
in a couple dynamic and uncoupledness is
every natural dynamic of most natural
diamonds are uncoupled there's a whole
story about that i'm i'm not getting
into it now
uh and and this is the result it already
stated okay
let me give you a proof of that i have i
have three minutes i'll give you one
minute proof okay it's beautiful
okay uh well i mean i think it's
beautiful but it's it's a nice uh okay
so
assume that c sub t is the forecast okay
forecast the time t
then everybody takes this forecast and
applies to it his own
approximate best reply function let's
call it g that was in the previous slide
the notation was introduced in the slide
that i jumped over quickly so the play
is going to be g of ct
okay so anytime the forecast or what's
going to happen tomorrow is a certain c
the play is going to be g of c
now let's think about that uh every time
the forecast was a certain c
the play was actually exactly the same
so so so when the forecast was c the
play was g of c next time the forecast
was c the play was exactly the same g of
c so when i look at all the days on the
forecast was c the play was always the
same g of c
so the average play is g of c so what
does it mean to be calibrated it means
that g of c and c
c was the forecast g or g of c was the
actual thing that happened they must be
close to one another so that's what
calibration means well it's continuous
calibration g being that's why you need
g to be a continuous function okay but
that's the idea calibration says that
what actually happened is what was
forecasted
then since g is an approximate best
reply i claim that this implies that the
player time t is an approximate nash
equilibrium formally just apply the
function g to both sides
and you get the g of the play equals the
play approximately that says that the
play is the best reply to itself within
delta okay that's all
okay now the question is why
do we need continuous calibration okay
why this is this work with standard
calibration with standard calibration no
way you can get natural equilibrium you
need for this continuous calibration why
okay and the reason we need continuous
calibration first of all it's
deterministic the fact that it's
deterministic means that everyone is
going to get the same forecast because
everyone is going to use the same
forecasting
procedure in the stochastic case even if
everybody uses the same forecasting
procedure remember you have to do
randomization so i was so the
forecasting procedure says with
probability half forecast 25 percent
probability half forecast 70 percent my
optimization came up 25
some of the assets optimization came out
seventy percent that's it we get
different forecasts and the whole thing
breaks down
since forecasts are deterministic then
it's the same forecast for all players
we can keep having the same forecast all
along where each one runs the algorithm
the procedure of forecasting at home
okay on his own computer but we know
that he's going to get the same result
okay
second thing which is probably the most
important issue is
the leakiness okay
vigness says
even if the forecast leaks and the
actions may depend on the forecast
nevertheless you can keep being
continuously calibrated
okay that's the importance of continuous
calibration continue unlike regular
calibration
where if the forecast leaks out it's
known before the laymaker makes his
decision then calibration cannot be
guaranteed
remember the below half above a half
kind of strategy
then for
deterministic continuous calibration
even if the forecast is known
and the actions are made to depend on
the forecast you can
guarantee
that the result is continuously
calibrated that's the power of
continuous calibration okay overcome
sneakiness you can allow actions to
depend on forecast okay
uh
okay calibration means this a fixed
point okay those things are clear
so that's once you get this fixed point
and clearly you get a national level now
again let me make it clear i'm not
suggesting that this is a good dynamic
in practice because this requires you to
solve a fixed point problem every day
it's just a concept okay the concept
says if you use continuous calibration
deterministic on this calibration then
you can get nash behavior period by
period
okay let me jump over that and let me
give you now the summary okay i'm that's
my last slide so
there is
our paper also makes a
very strong case about this distinction
between the two universes the mini max
universe and the fixed point universe
again for computer science people this
these distinctions are very clear but
i'm now trying to sell it to economists
as well in game tourists and so on so
again uh the things are powerless those
universes are very parallel in the mini
max universe i have stochastic forecast
hedging fixed point universe i have the
deterministic forecast energy
this is mn procedures versus fp
procedures i get classic calibration in
the minimax universe i get smooth
calibration or should say continuous
calibration in the fixed point universe
i get correlated equilibria in the first
i get nash equilibrium the second i get
quality equilibria's time average on me
plus in the fixed point universe i get
nash equilibria period by period
okay
and uh i said that's last slide sorry
let me just show an example of perfect
calibration
okay sorry a perfect hedging sorry not
perfect calibration perfect hedging okay
i hope you remember your english what
hedging means that's a
that's a
photograph i took at the chateau de
villendre
in the lower valley and i'm done
sorry i think i went over two minutes
over time but that's it
okay we uh any questions from the
audience
[Music]
hey so you mentioned that
i don't actually need to know anything
about the future i can just backcast but
what if i do have some context and i do
feel like i know something about the
future
uh is that a formalization of like can i
do better
can i can i get you can i get you with
this question to open my session in may
by talking mate that's exactly the
answer to this question
i'm going to is that's cali beatty now
if you're not going to to be there
look on my webpage the paper on cali
beating i think it's a it's a it's a
good paper well i mean i'm not objective
of course but i think it explains it's
again the issue that suppose you have an
expert
that really knows something okay
now but it's not calibrated it turns out
that it's not calibrated now we can
always calibrate someone uh we know how
to calibrate i mean do forecast hedging
but if you do but if you do that you are
going to lose all the expertise the guy
had
question can you do both answer yes in
fact in a trivial way
okay in an easy way okay you know
exposed stands out to do it quite easy
and that's how to preserve your
expertise and also get calibration on
top of it okay so it's not just that you
can get calibration for sure you can get
calibration on top of whatever you
already have
okay and uh
and i think it's a it's a it's a very
it's a nice it's a nice extra step that
uh
as i said
come in may you'll hear about it i hope
so
i'll probably read the paper uh right
now so sorry yeah i won't be able to
wait till may i'll probably read it like
soon so yeah yeah go ahead go ahead and
if you have comments i'm yes yes i'm you
know
but uh i mean i i want to give you know
some advertising for simon's institute
you know
very nicely invited
any more more questions
yes
[Music]
thank you
just just a question uh perhaps a very
generic one but uh
this the whole calibration technology is
in a sense
somehow
uh
meta because uh once we have a
calibration is what sorry sorry
meta it's it's like a meta algorithm it
is like a meta processing the sense that
once you have as input a
a calibrated uh
a calibrated procedure then you can
apply it to a game
and best respond to that game and you
get you get your uh equilibrium
convergence results so uh precisely
because it it is based
in no small part to
having
you know a variational in quality
underneath
my question is do you think it can be
applied also to
games with continuous action spaces
whose nash equilibria are also described
by uh
standby variational qualities and
get a similar equilibrium and get
similar equilibrium nash equilibrium
convergence results in the class of
continuous games
yes definitely i mean i think that again
uh
in my my old work with andromeda scholar
at some point i mean we started with
final games at some point you started we
looked at continuous games everything
extends now again look until you sit
down and do it but i i don't think i
mean
i presented it for final games because
that's uh
the the the simplest way to present the
concepts but i see no problem again
there will be technology
you know the integrals and measurability
i'm sorry i should actually clarify uh
something i realized my question was
incomplete i don't mean with mixed
strategies over oh i don't really find
anything
i mean
i said
this is why i mentioned the variation in
quality yeah yeah yeah okay sorry
yes i expect the answer to be to be the
same because
because again uh the mixture comes when
your space is discreet and then you have
to get this this uh smoothing out this
you have to you have to convexify it yes
and that's where the probability
distributions enter once you are given a
continuous space continuous action
spaces uh convex you know again convex
continuous action spaces i mean you you
should
principally can work in that space
without problem yes and again i can't
say for this is that exactly or can i i
mean but but you know other results and
dynamics that that i did work on they
extend the game as i said with some
technical issues here and there but yes
you get these purifications uh
uh
yes you
you you save on the contrary i mean you
once you don't have probability
distributions you also save on using
material torrents you just get
essentially
things like blackwell there is a version
of blackwell which becomes quite a
triviality that you can do it in
continuous spaces and then you don't
need probability distributions yes but
everything works the same except instead
of expectation you already take take the
the point itself yeah so in some sense
it simplifies in the other cases there
are some again measurabilities
integration issues but they are they are
technical and minor that's again
that's what i expect to happen here so
the answer to your question is yes i
would be very surprised if something
like this would not happen i mean
because there are enough similar kind of
approaches where this works beautifully
yes so this should work here as well
yes one more
more question
very nice talk thank you very much
so yesterday morning
we had a discussion about another one of
your theorems
about uncoupled dynamics which i thought
the theorem said would not lead to nash
equilibrium and this morning we saw a
theorem of yours where i think if i
understood uncoupled dynamics did lead
to nash equilibrium so luckily both of
these theorems are by you so yeah you uh
perhaps reconcile those results for us
yeah okay so so the question is the
setup okay um
[Music]
again what do we mean by kappa dynamics
i mean what is behind it here is the
anchor dynamic plus
plus the the calibration procedure that
is behind it and that solves very
difficult problems in some sense okay uh
so when when the tolerance on
uncoupled dynamics not being able to to
get close to nash equilibria
they always have additional additional
assumptions like finite memory like
finite recall like uh final computation
uh like amount of time that it takes so
so they cannot be they have to be taken
in context okay there is no universal
thing okay
universally what i can say is that that
uncoupled dynamics have a very hard time
getting
ever
i think i think at some point i use
dynamically complex okay
the dynamic complexity of such dynamics
not
is very high if we want to reach nash
equilibrium okay so they require either
amount of time that is huge or recall
huge recall i mean they cannot be finite
automata they cannot be simple kind of
dynamics okay simple uncoupled
okay sorry uh let me let me
let me say it in a simple way
simple uncoupled dynamics
cannot reach nash equilibrium question
is what is simple okay
now my answer is almost any any way that
you are going to define simple is going
to work for that tolerance
so ankapo dynamics can get you to nash
equilibria like here but they need to be
extremely complex like for example
solving a fixed point problem every day
now solving a fixed point problem every
day you know i'm not sure how many
people solve a fixed point problem you
know once in their lifetime
but
for sure not not every day so those are
extremely complex dynamics this is not
as i said those are not practical
dynamics they are proof of concept they
show how the concepts match together uh
if you want more more on this uh on this
question um
there is a there is a paper called
adaptive heuristics that uh that
essentially serves the literature up to
2000 and i don't remember when i when i
wrote that and
[Music]
i'm not sure sorry i'm not sure no no i
take it back sorry there is a book okay
uh you can find everything on my web
page
the introduction to the book of andron
myself
called the simple adaptive dynamics
okay you can find it on my webpage
look for the introduction it's an
extensive introduction that discusses
exactly this point in detail
okay
so uh if you want to
again it's it's it's not something i
mean i can what i did is essentially a
very short take and not very precise
but uh
but as i said uh nash equilibrium
dynamically complex correlated
equilibrium are dynamically simple which
means in terms of uncapped dynamics the
simple and capital dynamics will get to
correlated equilibria extremely complex
and capital dynamics are required to get
anything like nash equilibria
which is not should not be a surprise to
get fixed point you cannot do it by by
linear methods you cannot do it by mean
max method you need fixed point methods
okay there is no way
that you can get to fixed point without
using something of the order of explain
sergio maybe on a on a slightly related
point because we were discussing your uh
impossibility result yesterday your
result if we remember correctly uh
required uh determinism right and
continuous time
right for uh the dynamics not
for them not to converse to us right
so maybe yeah
there are again many variants of this
result uh one is the original one was
this continuous time if i remember
correct is differential equations yes
which was quite uh yeah but then there
are then i i think the the better paper
is the one that when we do it with
finite recall it's kind of results where
yes you can do that no you cannot do
that yes you can do that it's a kind of
uh
possibility an impossibility coming one
after the other
i don't remember the title of that but
uh
has to do with a couple dynamics in the
title uh
i can find out if you want
uh
let me see
sorry i'm uh
now it's very hard to find anything
i have to i have to go to surgery we
have intense interest for more questions
maybe i will allow like two last
questions so okay okay
i can send you i can send you some by
email if you want uh uh
but again what is it uh
if you look at the book which is a
collection of papers i mean again all of
the papers appear in in the
on my webpage so it's very easy my
webpage is pretty well organized because
i'm using it that's my way of finding
things
so uh
so uh
okay so go ahead there was some other
questions yeah i just wanted to uh just
one small clarification uh on uh on how
to uh if i had to see if i'm reading
correctly your results your your result
uh
it does not actually imply the
convergence of the sequence of mixed
strategies to the natural equilibrium
though right
no no no none of that
except in very special cases dynamics
never get your point wise convergence
what it says is that when you are far
enough in time you are going to be close
to some security yeah every period there
may be a very different nash equilibrium
that is in fact since this is period by
period there is no connection between
the periods we are not saying anything
every period may be a very different
nash equilibrium of course if there is
only one then or you know the
neighborhood of financial illegal but in
principle uh
for correlated equilibria for nashua
it's always you approach the set which
means after enough time you are close to
some point but very different point at
different points in time and in fact you
can wander around that's what usually
those dynamics do
yeah the only reason i wanted to make
this clarification was because your
impossibility result states that
uncoupled dynamics be they deterministic
uh with a continuous time or discrete
cannot converge to nash equilibrium so
yeah
there is no there is no contradiction in
between
your results right no no no because the
counter example there was a game is a
unique nash so being close to the set is
when there is a unique match that's
that's uh
that's the same
okay but in general in general the
impossibility results later in
possibility results not the first one
are really talking about being close to
the set of nash equilibria any
possibilities about that so again
the paper i'm talking about is
stochastic and capital dynamics in nash
equilibria
okay
gb 2006
that you asked me previously yeah but
that that that explains this a little
bit more detail
so i just had a high level conceptual
question so
a lot i'm not super familiar with this
area but you get the if you use uh
expert learning or the exponential
update you get these no regret kind of
bounds how does how does your the theory
presented today relate to the this other
theory of the kind of expert algorithms
there's also alternative ways which i
know computer scientists are very
very much like to do this exponential
weight updating and so on uh
i think that they are much more complex
than what we propose forecast hedging is
much simpler uh also all those uh kind
of methods have uh have a
problem that you need to know in advance
what capital t is
you have to know what what the horizon
is and if you change your eyes and you
have to change the method in the middle
uh what we present is it doesn't have
this thing i mean it's already all our
methods are already from the
uh for quality equilibria and
and this they are they are much simpler
but again one can look at this is a
black box it doesn't matter i mean you
can use whatever your method is we think
that forecast hedging is a good method
is a good way to understand
first of all what's really going on and
because you know you say it's also
weights why do they work i mean why does
exponential waiting works yes i mean
it's technical i think the idea of
separating between forecast hedging
which means take out the effect of the
unknown or uncontrolled weather
that's a hedging once you do that you
get calibration okay so the only
question is how do you do that well you
get those forecast aging tools okay so
conceptually it it it clarifies what's
really going on where calibration comes
from and you understand again that this
is back casting and not forecasting and
everything i think becomes very clear
and somehow things now fit together well
previously it was mysterious black boxes
that mixed together and was not clear at
least in my mind okay i think that now i
understand things much better
okay but sure you can get calibration
with those networks no regret methods
any use use your favorite no regret
method i think ours has an advantage
they are simpler
right and clear more clear but
feel free to use whatever you want
yes a big round of applause for surgery
thank you
okay thank you